laid out for the world to see this is
Saudi Arabia's case against Iran on the
stage to cruise missiles and the remains
of at least seven drones they are claim
the Saudis what's left of a sortie of 25
drones and missiles which hit two oil
facilities last weekend and another back
in may indicate women of Iranian Iran
origin the launch site of the attack
attack could not have originated from
Yemen in the audience diplomats and
military officers from embassies around
the world they were shown footage
apparently showing the drones flying
just before impact and the most detailed
images so far of the damage at one of
the sites this UAV DeltaWing and all the
component that we have recovered and we
have analyzed through our experiment it
show the capability of the Iranian
regime with maps the Saudis claimed that
the range of the drones and missiles
ruled out a launch from Yemen Saudi
Arabia wants to demonstrate the danger
Iran and its regional influence poses
the spokesman repeatedly dismissed any
suggestion that the missiles and drones
came from Yemeni rebels just to clarify
you did say that they definitely were
not launched from Yemen correct yes
Iran has consistently claimed that
Yemeni Houthi rebels were behind the
attack the rebels themselves have taken
credit for it and they're known to have
used similar drones supplied by Iran to
hit sites nearer the Saudi Yemen border
Iranian president said again today that
Houthi rebels were responsible and he
praised them for retaliating against the
Saudis for their four-year bombing
campaign in Yemen the unprecedented
events of the past week have left
ordinary Saudis anxious and looking
towards their leadership and the
kingdom's young Crown Prince the power
behind the throne also needs to reassure
his allies and energy clients
the assessment here is that the weekend
strikes are just the latest largest
example of Iran poking its enemies but
his response really matters that it is a
very difficult calculation to strike
back militarily and risk escalating
things massively or to do nothing
substantial and appear weak tonight the
US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is in
Saudi Arabia a planned news conference
with the Saudi foreign minister was
postponed it is still not clear how or
if America and Saudi Arabia will respond